Mà chở các nước Mỹ, Nhật Bàm, Hẳn Độ và Australia, Hày Còn Gọi là nhóm bộ tự,
hôm nay sau thằng năm đã nhất chỉ trên khai dự án xây dựng gà viện,
tạng đạo của phí dì và thì các thỏ thận về khoảng 30 lược cùng an ninh năng lượng.
Rui được coi là nữ lực thúc đầy và trò của nhóm bộ tự,
tại khu cực an đồ dương thế bây giờ,
dự án tại của đạo phí dì là hạ tâm Trung lâu bian của nhóm bộ tự,
ngoại trường Mỹ mắt con biểu cho biết,
dự án sẽ có phần giải quyết tình trạng thiếu nó lực cảm biển tại các quốc đạo thay bình dương,
bốn nước cũng công bố quân khu hợp đá về khoảng 30 trên lượng,
nhằm thăng cường truyền công ứng, lâu tư khai thác,
trên biến và tài trẻ khoảng 30 quan trọng.
Tên bộ Trung của nhóm bộ tự, cũng bây tỏ quan gái về tình hình đại bình đông và bình hoa đông,
tông thời phản đối các hành động gây dạng loại thương mạng 2.
Trung Quốc sau đó chỉ trích trên bộ Trung của nhóm,
cho rằng thật thất của cực không nên nhằm vào bên thứ 3,
hãy tạo ra đối đầu trong quân hệ của tế.